Hi guys and welcome to video 18.
Previously, we looked at modeling
historical portfolio performance and in
this video, we're going to continue with
analyzing things at the portfolio level,
but this time we're looking at volatility.
Now, for those of you that have done the
introduction to professional trading
masterclass, some of this video is going
to contain information that you've already
covered. And in fact, you're going to
be way ahead in your general understanding
of volatility and its importance. So for
you guys that haven't done that course, I
suggest that you have a look at it because
you will find it extremely useful to
supplement what we go through in the next
couple of videos. In this video, we're
going to cover plenty of ground and as a
little insight into what's sort of coming
up, here's what we're going to go through.
We're going to discuss what volatility
means to traders and portfolio managers
and how we measure it. I'm then going
going to talk about realized volatility
and briefly cover an example of a
distribution of returns analysis, which is
a type of volatility analysis. And we're
going to work through an example there at
the portfolio level. From there, we're
going to move on to modeling what's called
expected portfolio volatility. And that's
really going to be the core component of
what this video is all about. I'll start
there by explaining the theory behind the
model. And that will give you guys a big
insight in
what matters when constructing what
matters when constructing an efficiently
diversified portfolio that enhances your
risk reward profile. Then we'll move on to
some scenario analysis using the model.
And by doing that, we'll sort of
demonstrate the benefits of adding small
and mid cap stocks to the portfolios as
well. And then finally, I'll talk about
how you can use the model for constructing
or conducting, I should say, scenario
analysis in
your own portfolios and your own
portfolios. And I'll teach you the
practicalities of using the model to help
you understand how changes in portfolio
structure will likely affect the overall
portfolio volatility that you're likely to
see. So there's going to be loads of
important learning points as we go through
the video and all of those sort of
practical elements. So make sure you pay
close attention. And I will also give you
a short synopsis of all of that important
stuff that we've covered at the end of the
video as well.
Before I go any further, let me point out
that this video is heavily connected to
the next one in the PTM series. And in
fact, there's going to be a lot of points
in this video where I deliberately stop
short for full explanation, particularly
when it comes to portfolio theory and
diversification, because it's something
that we're going to cover in so much
detail in the next video as well. So to
that end, what I would say is don't worry
a whole lot if you feel
there are some gaps in the next one.
your risk return profile. That's the goal.
Okay, before I start rambling on about
volatility, let's take a look at this
spreadsheet that we have here, which I'll
be using throughout the video, and you'll
be able to get hold of in the download
section for this video. So in this
spreadsheet, we've got seven sheets, and
I'm going to mention them now in the order
that we're going to work through them in
the video. After I've introduced the
concept of volatility, we're going to
begin in this spreadsheet here by looking
at
the standard deviation calculation. The
standard deviation calculation tab. That's
where I'll show you how to calculate
volatility using the industry standard
methodology. The second sheet that we're
going to look at is the portfolio DOR tab.
And in that one, I'm going to talk through
a type of volatility analysis called a
distribution of returns. Now I'm not going
to spend too much time in that sheet as
it's something that's going to be covered
extensively or already has been covered
extensively in the IPLT course.
but it will be enough to give you a good
idea of the statistical process. And we'll
be using data from the portfolios that we
looked at in the previous video. After
that, we're going to move on to learning
some portfolio volatility theory, before
then shifting our attention to running
some calculations based on various
scenarios, using the portfolio volatility
model in the practical sheet. And the rest
of the tabs here are really just
supporting
data sheets that help the portfolio. And
I'll spend a bit of time explaining them
later. So as I said previously, this video
is going to be all about calculating and
understanding volatility at the portfolio
level. But before we get into that, we
need to discuss what volatility actually
is.
Assets in this case can refer to anything
from individual instruments like a share
in a company, all the way up to index
funds and portfolios made up of multi
asset class long short positions.
Volatility is really important to get to
grips with. And as anyone that's done the
IPLT course knows, it's often
misunderstood. And most people think of
volatility only as risk, but actually
forget or don't realize that it also
presents or
represents opportunity. If there was no
chance to represent opportunity. If there
was no chance to profit from price
fluctuations. If there was no chance to
profit from price fluctuations, then there
would be no chance to profit from price
fluctuations. And so we actually need
volatility at both the individual asset
level and the portfolio level.
In the IPLT course, we discussed how one
of the core retail trading mistakes is
trying to trade assets with little
inherent volatility over very short
timeframes. And by recognizing those
faults through volatility analyses such as
computing the distribution of returns on
various assets, we identified that the two
most important ways to increase volatility
and hence opportunity for profit is by
trading assets with a larger inherent
volatility.
such as small cap or mid cap equities, and
also by extending the time horizon of our
trades.
By conducting volatility analysis over
various assets and timeframes, we
concluded that a sweet
spot for trading time horizons is about
one to three months on average. This gives
positions
plenty of time to move by larger
magnitudes, as opposed to the sort of tiny
fluctuations that you
typically see on a daily basis or hourly
basis. People that don't understand the
difference in
volatility across assets and asset classes
usually have very warped perspectives over
what instruments
they think have prices that move a lot.
For example, it's very common in the
retail trading industry for
retail traders to think that the most
volatile asset class is currencies or
forex, which is completely
incorrect. And any kind of sort of
volatility analysis worth its salt would
quickly discover
that that's not right. The only reason why
it appears that way is because brokers
offer huge
leverage on FX pairs and retail clients
don't realize that the volatility that
they're seeing
in their positions is entirely driven by
that leverage. So that brings me on to a
third way
to increase volatility in your positions
in your portfolio, which as you've
probably just gathered
is to take on leverage. However, leverage
also increases transaction costs. And
unless it's fully
understood, it can be quite dangerous,
which is why I said that increasing
trading, your trading time
horizon and choosing higher volatility
assets to trade are much more important
methods of increasing
volatility. That being said, if you do
understand leverage and the financial
products that you're
using to obtain that leverage, then it can
be very useful, which is one of the
reasons why at ITPM,
we often structure trades using options.
So you guys now have an idea of what
volatility is and why it's
important. Basically, the key takeaway
here is that volatility represents much
more than just risk. It also
represents opportunity for profit. And on
that basis, we need to ensure that we're
trading the right assets
over the right timeframes to ensure we
have plenty of opportunity to make money.
Again, the IPLT course
goes into a lot more detail on this with
lots of analysis to go with it. So I
strongly recommend you take a
look at that course if you haven't
already. Okay, so now we know volatility
is based on the magnitude of
fluctuations in asset prices and asset
returns. Let's move on to how we can
actually measure that.
There are actually quite a few ways to
calculate volatility, but the most used
and therefore probably
the most important measure is a
statistical measure called a standard
deviation. If you ever hear
people talking about volatility in the
financial world, nine out of 10 times,
this will be the measure
that they're using. Now, I know that we've
basically covered standard deviations
before in a way in the
money supply video and in other courses as
well if you've seen those, but I want to
take a moment in
this video to kind of get into the weeds
of the standard deviation calculation
itself. Since this video is
all about volatility at the portfolio
level, I just thought that was a good idea
to kind of clear things up.
So to explain what exactly a standard
deviation is and how to calculate it,
let's move over to the
standard deviation calculation sheet now
so I can show you how this measure of
volatility works.
So in this sheet here I've got a small
series of numbers that we're going to
calculate the volatility
4. The numbers are 8, 3, 5, 7, 11, 4, 6
and 4. What I'm going to do in this
example is break down the
calculation for the standard deviation of
this very simple series into a number of
steps. And the idea
here is that by going through this method
you're going to understand how the measure
works and you'll be
a bit more confident in using it in
applications further ahead. So in almost
all measures of volatility,
we take a reference point of a series of
numbers and run some kind of calculation
that measures
how much the series of numbers fluctuates
around the reference point. A standard
deviation does this
by measuring the volatility of a series of
numbers around their average. That gives
us a good starting
point which is to calculate the average of
this series. So let me do that over here.
In cell H2,
I'm just going to type equals average okay
open brackets d2 colon d9 so selecting the
array d2 to d9
close brackets and press enter. Next once
we've got the average of our data set what
we're really
interested in is figuring out how
different each individual data point in
the series is to that mean
or average and basically the further away
all of these points are from the mean the
more volatile the data
set. So the next stage is to calculate
those differences. So in cell E2 I'm just
going to type
a formula here which is going to be d2
which is the starting number in our series
minus h2 and I'm going to
fix that reference by putting dollar signs
around the column and row references. So
that's just going
to take the series value minus the mean
and then we'll copy that formula down from
E2 to cell E9. So now
we've got all of our differences. The
positive and negative results here show
that some of the points
are obviously above the mean and some are
below the average. However if we were to
average all of these
positive and negative differences now we
would get a value of zero as an output
because the positives
and negatives cancel out and so our value
for volatility would then be zero which
clearly isn't
a good representation of the sort of
dispersion that we have around the mean in
the data set. So what we
need to do here is treat all the
differences equally and one way we can do
that is to square the results
so that they all become positive and then
after that we can average these numbers to
create a
single value and square root it again to
undo the squared changes we made earlier
and then that's it.
So in cell F2 I'm going to type the
formula equals E2 to the power of 2 so
that's just squaring that
difference and then I'm going to copy that
formula down from F2 to F9 so that we have
all of our squared
differences and then in cell I2 I'm going
to take the average of all of those
squared differences F2
to F9 so equals average open brackets and
then choosing the array F2 to F9 close
brackets and then
in cell J2 I'm going to type equals SQRT
that stands for square root so the square
root function in Excel
so equals SQRT open brackets I2 so we're
taking the square root of the average of
all of those squared
differences so basically the square root
of the value that we see in I2. Now that
value that we've got in
J2 is our standard deviation value for
that series of numbers. Now fortunately
you don't have to go through
all of those stages to calculate a
standard deviation each time you want to
you can just use an inbuilt
Excel function to do all the work instead
but the point of going through all of that
was so that you
kind of understand and feel comfortable
with how standard deviations work and
basically a standard
deviation uses a method to sort of tell us
the average distance of each data point in
the series to
the overall mean in that series. So to
calculate this quickly in Excel all you
need to do is the
following I'm going to select cell K2 now
and type in a formula which is equals
STDEV.P open brackets
and then select our array our original
series cells D2 to D9 and close brackets.
Now that's going to
calculate what's called the population
standard deviation which is appropriate
for what we're doing here.
What you might see me do later in the
series or actually probably you will see
me do later in the
series is use a slightly different
standard deviation formula which is
STDEV.S that stands for a sample
standard deviation okay because
realistically that's what you should be
using if you're kind of estimating
a standard deviation based on a sample of
data not the entire population okay in
this in this example that
doesn't really matter I don't want to get
into that too much just don't worry about
the difference that
I'm kind of using here and other times in
the series between those two slightly
different versions of the
standard deviation calculation. But anyway
when I put in that formula that population
standard deviation
formula you can see that I get exactly the
same result as we did before but obviously
a lot faster.
What I've also done here is below created
a chart as a reminder about what the
standard deviation
formula actually does and I'm hoping that
that sort of visual visual aid might help
you understand what
I've been talking through so far. So by
all means check that out when you download
this spreadsheet
yourself there's some notes to go with it
as well and which will remind you what
we've been through and
hopefully make things clearer. Okay so
that's all there is to understanding and
being able to calculate
a standard deviation. As I said standard
deviations are the most common measures of
volatility for traders
and portfolio managers and now that you've
got that understanding I want to quickly
show you a volatility
analysis technique where we study the
distribution of returns of a portfolio and
it also incorporates within
it some standard deviation calculations or
measurements as well. Now in the IPLT
course we covered distribution
of returns analyses in lots of detail on
many assets and it helped us draw some of
the conclusions about
volatility that I mentioned earlier
especially when it comes to which assets
and asset classes and trading
time frames yield the most opportunity for
profit. In this video we're going to
employ the same techniques
as we did there but at the portfolio level
and because I've covered this type of
analysis in detail in the
previous course and I appreciate that many
of you will have done that course already
I'm not going to spend
loads of time on this section of the
video. Basically instead of learning how
to do this volatility analysis
from scratch I'm just going to guide you
through a pre-built analysis to save time
and we aren't going
to go into nearly as much detail here as
we did in the IPLT course. So a
distribution of returns analysis is
pretty much exactly as it sounds. What it
does is basically calculate and analyze
the returns of an asset
or an index or an index or portfolio and
pays particular attention to how those
returns are distributed in
terms of their empirical probability. What
that means is that over a given period we
can calculate all the
returns for an asset say the S&P 500 for
example and then group that data into
various ranges of returns.
The idea being that for example we can see
how often the S&P 500 has returned between
let's say 1 and 2 percent
compared to 2 or 3 percent on a weekly
basis over the period that we decide to
analyze. If that isn't
clear don't worry it will make sense when
we run through the examples on this sheet.
So what I've got
here is a pre-built distribution of
returns analysis for the two portfolios
that we looked at in the previous
video. This kind of analysis is what's
called a realized volatility analysis
because it examines the
volatility of the price or value of an
asset in the past. So what I've done here
is calculated the hypothetical
value of the two portfolios we considered
in the previous video using the
non-rebalance method. Those values
are recorded in columns B and C and the
time series of the portfolios run through
the first half of
2021 as you can see here. Portfolio one is
our large cap portfolio and portfolio two
is our mid and large cap
mixed portfolio. Remember both portfolios
are long six stocks and short four and
it's only the long side that changes in
our models.
I've put a list up the top here showing
the constituents of each portfolio as a
quick reminder to you so you
don't have to kind of think back to the
previous video too much. So the daily
returns for each portfolio
are calculated in columns D and E and
they're simply the percentage changes in
the value of each portfolio
on every trading day and it's those
returns that we then use to carry out the
volatility analysis that I've
got here on the right hand side. So over
on this side then I've split the analysis
into two parts the
statistics I've calculated in columns G to
K are for portfolio one and the large cap
portfolio and in
columns L to P we've got the statistics
that refer to portfolio two which is again
our large mid cap mixed
portfolio and each of these sections
contains subsections which can be split
into descriptive
statistics, a frequency table and a
histogram and a portfolio value chart. So
let's look at the
descriptive statistics first. We can see
that both portfolios have 106 daily return
values meaning the
portfolio values have been calculated over
107 days. We know from the last video that
portfolio one didn't
perform as well as portfolio two over the
period that we analyzed and so as we would
expect it has a
lower average daily return and a lower
maximum return over the period. Now the
returns might be lower for
portfolio one but the volatility is also
lower. If we look at the values of
standard deviation then we can
see that the daily standard deviation in
portfolio two is almost twice as large as
portfolio one and
again this is something you should have
expected given what we talked about in the
last video. I'm not
trying to say here that higher volatility
is better because actually all else being
equal it isn't.
What I am trying to show you is that in
order to generate higher returns it's
likely that you'll need
to take on greater volatility and
portfolio two reflects that. So let's move
on to the frequency
tables now in rows 22 to 37. What you can
see here are tables that count the number
of daily returns in
each series that land within certain
ranges. For example if we look at the
frequency table for portfolio one
we can see that five data points have a
value that lie between or that lies
between minus 0.98 percent
and minus 0.72 percent. Equally 22 daily
returns values are within the range from
0.07 percent to 0.33 percent
and so on. Aside from these tables telling
us the absolute frequency of data points
landing within certain
ranges they also tell us the empirical
probability. That is the probability given
the historical data
set and each of these ranges of returns
occurring. So for example we can see that
the range from 0.85 percent
to 1.12 percent only accounts for 2.83
percent of the data and so we could infer
that there's only a
2.83 percent probability of that range of
returns taking place on any given day
based on the historical
data set that we've analyzed. The
cumulative probability column is a
derivation of that and sequentially sums
up all the probability values for each
range starting from the lowest one. What
that allows us to say is
things like portfolio one has a roughly 85
percent chance that it returns less than
0.59 percent on a
given day for example based on the data
that we're looking at. Now I should point
out here that inferring
future probabilities with historical data
is tricky at the best of times and it
should definitely be avoided
when we're dealing with such a small data
set. Remember what we're really trying to
understand here is the
difference in volatility between the two
portfolios not what the probability of
certain ranges of returns
will be in the future. When we compare the
data between the two portfolios at the
frequency table level
we can make some quick inferences about
volatility again. So in portfolio two you
can see here that the ranges of
returns that have a probability of above
zero is much wider meaning returns can
vary obviously a lot more.
That backs up the summary that we obtained
from the descriptive statistics but this
obviously gives
gives us a bit more flavor by diving into
the details of the distributions. The
frequency table data
we've been looking at is then plotted into
charts in the rows below and this is just
a graphical representation
really of what we already know by looking
at the tables above but that being said it
can be easier to gauge
the shape of the distribution visually in
a histogram format. I won't go into too
much detail here about
how that's useful but I talked about it in
the context of things like skewness and
kurtosis statistics
in the IPLT videos so you can check that
out if you want to. Finally if you look at
the charts at the
bottom of this analysis sheet you'll see
plots of the two portfolios value over
time. As I said in the
last video plotting portfolio value is
easy enough to do and you can see here
that portfolio two outperforms
portfolio one quite significantly however
as we've seen at almost every stage of the
analysis here you can
also tell that there's more volatility in
the portfolio just by looking at the line
on the chart really
since you know the rises and declines in
value are steeper given that both charts
are scaled in the same
format. So that's a really quick synopsis
really of how you can use a distribution
of returns to
analyze your portfolio and its volatility.
This is kind of a great way of getting an
in-depth understanding
of how your portfolio has been working in
the past and that data can then be used to
derive certain
trading performance statistics which we're
going to cover later in the video series.
This kind of analysis
is also useful for being able to compare
the historical performance of two or more
portfolios
in terms of their risk and returns and
generally you'll find that as with
individual assets higher
volatility portfolios represent higher
risk but also higher reward. However that
being said that
relationship isn't as clear-cut in
portfolios because in well-structured
portfolios we can actually
drastically improve the amount of return
we get for any given level of risk by
understanding the
principles of diversification and
correlation. That brings me nicely onto
the next section of the video
where I'm going to talk about portfolio
theory and modeling portfolio volatility.
What we've just
covered by looking at the real performance
of a portfolio is how to calculate and
understand realized
volatility. That's something you can only
do after the fact meaning that only once
you have a live
portfolio up and running and you're
recording its value on a daily or weekly
basis or whatever frequency
you're recording on can you then start
performing an in-depth volatility analysis
as we've looked at
briefly there. What I want to show you now
is how to calculate expected portfolio
volatility which will help you
understand your portfolio construction as
it currently stands and also help you
model any structural changes
you might make. The difference here really
compared to looking at realized volatility
as we did before is
that we're going to use a model where we
can estimate what the volatility of the
portfolio that we currently hold is
and also what it might be going forward as
well as how it can change when the inputs
of the portfolio are varied
such as you know the number of assets, the
weightings of the positions and so on. Now
obviously this has a number of benefits
such as allowing you to understand the
potential levels of risk and opportunity
in the portfolio.
You're able to model a portfolio's
volatility under various scenarios by
changing inputs like the
constituents of the portfolio and their
weightings as I've just said and because
you can model these
various scenarios by changing portfolio
inputs it also means you can use these
techniques to try and
target certain levels of volatility in the
portfolio as well. Now that's not
something commonly done on the retail
side but in the investment management
industry it's quite common. So before we
move on to the
practical elements of using this portfolio
volatility model I want to take you guys
through some basic
portfolio theory and if you understand
this stuff it's going to be incredibly
powerful
and enable you to really understand how to
build well-structured portfolios with
great risk return profiles.
Essentially what I think is really
important here is to understand how to
calculate portfolio
volatility i.e. how the equation behind
the model that we're going to use actually
works. Now I'm not
going to do this in in massive detail
regarding the equation itself but what I
am going to discuss with you
guys is what the inputs are into the
equation and that will then give us an
understanding of the drivers
behind portfolio volatility. With that
being said once all the underlying
positions in the portfolio are
defined the three sets of inputs required
for calculating and hence modeling
portfolio volatility
are firstly the weightings of the
individual assets in the portfolio. This
is something that we looked
at in the previous video but basically the
weighting for each position in the
portfolio is just the gross
exposure of that position divided by the
gross exposure of the overall portfolio.
The variance of every asset
in the portfolio is also an input. The
variance is just a measure of volatility
and actually it's
mathematically equal to the standard
deviation squared. And finally we need the
co-variances of all the assets in the
portfolio.
Now co-variances are measures of the
relationship between two assets and so
every pair of assets or positions in the
portfolio
will have a pairwise covariance value that
defines their linear relationship. And I'm
going to talk in more detail
about co-variances and correlations in the
next video but a positive covariance value
means that the two assets being measured
tend to tend to move in the same direction
at the same time and vice versa. If you've
heard about
correlation or the Pearson's coefficient
of correlation more specifically then
that's just basically a
normalized covariance meaning it's bound
between the values of one and minus one
whereas covariance is unbounded.
Now in this video and the next one I might
kind of use covariance and correlation
terms kind of
interchangeably to represent the same
thing because really what I'm talking
about when I use those terms
although they are slightly mathematically
different what I'm talking about is how
they kind of define
the linear relationships between two
assets. So if you want to get to grips
further with statistics like
variances and co-variances then you can
check out the basic statistics guide pdf
which is a download file
available earlier in the video series.
Realistically though there's no need to
dive into the details too
much there and you just need to know that
variance and standard deviations are
measures of volatility
and that the variance is just the standard
deviation squared and covariance and
correlation statistics
are measures of the linear relationships
between two assets. So let's go back to
the inputs for our expected
portfolio volatility model. Weightings are
easy to define as you've seen in the
previous video we can
just assign a percentage weight to each
position as we wish to as long as the
total sum of the gross
weightings equal 100%. The other inputs
require a little bit more thought though
because when we're
talking about expected portfolio
volatility the variance and covariance
values that we use are just
estimates of what we expect those values
to be in the future and there's a number
of ways to come up with
these estimates but I want to keep things
simple here. So the way we're going to
obtain these estimates is
just by using a sample of past returns for
all of the individual assets in the
portfolio and then
calculating variance and covariance terms
from that data for each asset and then
that will kind of be
used as our estimations for those future
values as well. Okay so now we know what
inputs are required
let's move on to the portfolio volatility
equation itself. As I said previously I'm
not going to go
into any complicated maths here I just
want to outline how the equation works
rather than teach you the
details because knowing how the equation
works and what affects its output is far
more important for you
guys to learn than being able to write out
the equation yourselves like we're doing
you know a university
exam or something like that. So as I
explained previously portfolio volatility
depends on three
sets of inputs the weightings of each
position in the portfolio and the variance
of those positions
and the covariances between all of those
positions. Let's ignore weightings for
now.
A typical way to look at the variances and
covariances of assets in the portfolio is
through
something called a variance covariance
matrix. Now I've got an example here which
I'm going to use to
explain the fundamentals of the portfolio
volatility equation. So here's our example
variance covariance
matrix. Imagine a hypothetical portfolio
that contains the assets that we've
denoted by the tickers that you can
see in the row and column titles of this
table. The values contained in this matrix
are all covariance
calculations based on weekly returns over
the same historic period for each asset.
As I said before
covariances represent the pairwise
relationship or linear relationship
between two assets and so every value
you see here is calculated based on two
stocks which are the tickers in the
representative column and row titles for
each
cell. So for example we can see here that
the covariance between Facebook and Disney
is 0.00063.
When covariance calculations are run on a
single asset we get the variance of that
asset. So these values are
shown on the diagonal where the
representative row and column tickers are
equal to each other. So for
example we can see here that the variance
calculated for Visa stock in this example
is 0.0009.
If you look at the table as a whole you
can see that the numbers either side of
the diagonal variance
values are symmetrical. That's because if
you take the covariance of x with y it's
the same as the
covariance of y with x or if we exchange
those x and y values. If you take the
covariance of Facebook
with Disney it's the same as taking the
covariance of Disney with Facebook if that
makes sense.
So the question is why am I showing you
this kind of random covariance matrix and
how does it actually
help us understand the portfolio
volatility equation? Well let's imagine
you want to work out the
expected volatility for a portfolio that
is long all of these stocks. The matrix
here provides estimates
using historical returns of all the
variance and covariance terms you would
need to calculate this
portfolio's volatility. What I'm saying is
volatility for a portfolio of these stocks
is a function of all
of the terms that you can see here. The
key reason why I wanted to illustrate this
in this way is because
it actually gives us a really important
insight into the importance of covariances
or the relationships
between portfolio positions to the overall
output of portfolio volatility. For
example let's imagine that
we have a portfolio that only contains one
stock let's say visa the variance of that
portfolio would
just be equal to the variance of visa and
the volatility of that portfolio would
just be the square root of
the variance so the standard deviation is
is typically the volatility value that
we're talking about
and standard deviation is the square root
of the variance. If we then include Disney
into the portfolio
the variance of the portfolio becomes a
function of the variance terms of both
Disney and visa and the
covariance terms between them so it's a
function of two variance terms and two
covariance terms.
In a three stock portfolio let's imagine
we're now including Nike or Nike as well
portfolio variance would then
become a function of three variance terms
and six covariance terms. This is the
important part to
understand as assets are added portfolio
variance becomes a function of many more
covariance terms than it
does of variance terms and put simply what
we're saying here is that in any sort of
reasonably sized portfolio
it's the relationships of positions in the
portfolio quantified by you know either
covariance or
correlation terms not the volatility of
the individual assets that primarily
drives portfolio volatility.
To demonstrate this further I have built a
chart up at the top of this sheet that
illustrates these
principles in more detail. What this chart
shows is the volatility measured as a
standard deviation of
various portfolios given different
assumptions of correlation and volatility
in the individual constituents
of those portfolios. To make things simple
within each portfolio I have assumed that
all assets have equal weightings,
equal volatilities, equal volatilities and
equal correlations. So we're definitely
covering theoretical examples here but
they're still going to sort of enhance
your understanding of the principles that
I'm trying to get across.
So each portfolio is represented by a
different line in the chart and they all
have varying
assumptions of volatility and correlation
values. What I'm trying to demonstrate
through this chart is how both the
volatility of individual portfolio
constituents and the correlation terms
between them affect overall
portfolio volatility based on how many
positions are in the portfolio. You can
see here that every
portfolio has a reduction in volatility as
more assets are added which is always true
provided the new assets
are not perfectly correlated with the rest
of the portfolio i.e. equal to one.
The intercept on the left hand side and
the maximum volatility for each portfolio
therefore occurs when
there is only one asset in the portfolio
and that is equal to the volatility of the
single asset in the
portfolio as we discussed earlier. The
speed at which portfolio volatility then
decreases when new assets are
added which are added which we can see in
the the slope of these lines is dependent
on the correlation between
positions in the portfolio. If we take the
grey line for example the individual asset
volatilities are set
constant at 0.25 which is equal to 25% and
the correlation between all the assets in
the portfolio is set to 0.6
which is equal to 60 percent. So with one
asset in that portfolio the volatility of
the whole portfolio is
obviously equal to 25% but as more assets
are added to the portfolio volatility
decreases but not at a very
quick rate and to the point where
volatility barely changes as you add
assets beyond you know the numbers of
sort of 6 or 7. That's because the
correlation between all of the positions
is actually set quite high
at 0.6 as i said 60%. As a reference point
that might be the kind of outcome you get
if you're sort of long
only mega caps in similar sectors.
Conversely if you have a look at the
orange portfolio here we've assumed that
the
individual asset volatilities in the
portfolio are a little higher at 35% but
the correlations are lower
at 20%. In that case the portfolio
volatility starts 10% higher than the
previous portfolio the grey
portfolio but as more assets are added the
volatility actually continues lower than
the previous portfolio
and again that is due to the lower
correlations. I've labelled the orange
portfolio as an example of
being long short large and mid cap
equities. In reality in that kind of
portfolio the average
correlation may even be quite a bit lower
as we'll see in an example later. The
yellow portfolio changes
depending on the inputs that you enter
into the cells D3 and D4 here where you
can enter
values for pairwise correlations and asset
volatilities in the portfolio. These are
in
decimals so 0.2 means 20% for example and
I've restricted the correlation cell to
only accept values
between 0 and 1 because although negative
correlations within portfolios are
possible especially within
a long short portfolio I think it just
kind of complicates the concepts that I'm
trying to get across
you so that's why I've put a limit on it.
I don't want to add any kind of further
confusion. You can play
around with these values to get more of a
feel for how they affect portfolio
volatility so for example
here let's put in 0.05 so 5% correlation
and 50% volatility so 0.5 in this cell and
when you do that
you can see that the yellow portfolio
changes quite significantly. Obviously
when there's just one asset in that
portfolio
the portfolio volatility is 50% and then
because the correlations are set so low at
5% the steepness of
that curve i.e. the amount that risk or
volatility is reduced in that portfolio as
more assets are added
is sort of very quick so that the
volatility decreases at a very quick rate
as more assets are added.
So that's portfolio volatility theory out
of the way hopefully by going through a
variance covariance
matrix and looking at this chart you guys
understand a bit more about why
correlations between assets
are important and how they affect the
volatility of the overall portfolio.
Ultimately you know what we're
talking about here is the sort of positive
effects of diversification. At this stage
i do want to point
out a very important sort of practical
consideration to do with diversification.
Now you could be forgiven
for looking at the chart here and thinking
okay great all i need to do here is fill
my portfolio with loads
and loads and loads of positions and as
long as i can keep correlations low the
performance i will get in
terms of risk return will be awesome
because you know the volatility will be so
small. This is definitely
the wrong way to think about things
because the reality is that your portfolio
returns are going to be driven
by your higher quality ideas and over
diversifying outside of those sort of top
quality ideas is going
to significantly dilute your returns.
Basically you know you'll end up with a
pretty sort of pathetic
portfolio one that carries little risk but
also very little reward. Interestingly
though this is a problem
that professional managers can sometimes
face as well because usually it's sort of
to do with structural or
regulatory or liquidity constraints that
kind of force them into over diversifying
away from their core
positions. Retail traders though have no
excuses for this they don't have those
issues at least certainly not
not nearly as much so you know there's no
excuse for you guys kind of over
diversifying your portfolios.
Aside from over diversification diluting
returns you guys will find that it's
actually
very difficult to continuously find low
correlation ideas anyway and so
diversification driven risk
benefits are going to kind of taper off as
more assets are added anyway. As well as
that correlations
between assets aren't fixed and they can
change quite significantly. Again we'll
kind of look at that a
little bit in the next video. So that's
another reason why you shouldn't just
diversify
into apparently low correlation positions
for the sake of it. They have to be
fuelled by high quality
research to offer up the best chances for
success. Good retail traders should be
aiming for about 8 to
12 high quality high conviction positions
that have low correlations with each other
depending on the
capital that you have to play with maybe
you can expand that portfolio size a
little bit into the low
of the high quality. In the next video I'm
going to talk in a bit more detail about
correlation including
some pitfalls and things you should watch
out for so we're going to revisit a bit of
what I've just
talked about there and I'll also cover
some more sort of practical pointers when
doing your own
correlation analysis as well. For now
though I'm going to leave portfolio theory
there and we're going to
move on to some practical portfolio
volatility analysis using the rest of the
sheet.
So what we're going to do next is some
scenario analysis where we consider
various different portfolios
and see how volatility changes across
them. But before we do that let me explain
a bit more about how
this spreadsheet is set up. We've
obviously been through three sheets
already. Standard deviation,
calculation, portfolio distribution of
returns and portfolio volatility theory.
The asset volatility
summary sheet shows a table of various US
equities some of which you know you might
be familiar with
outside of these courses but some you will
also recognize from the previous video or
the IPLT course.
Inside the table each stock contains some
classification information such as market
capitalization and
sector information as well as volatility
calculations in various formats. So in the
blue section of the
table we have realized standard deviation
calculations using different frequencies
of data. If you want some
specifics about how these numbers have
been calculated then basically for each
company the standard deviation
of various frequencies of returns has been
calculated over the last 30 years of stock
price data before the 10th of
June 2021. So for example column I shows
the standard deviation of daily returns
for each stock over the
last 30 years prior to the 10th of June
2021. If a stock has less than 30 years of
historical data available
then the entire data set available is
used. Column J shows the standard
deviation for each stock using
weekly returns over the last 30 years and
so on. Beyond those blue columns of data
we have more
volatility values in a yellow section.
This section shows the implied volatility
values for each of these
stocks on the 10th of June 2021 using at
the money options. Implied volatility
isn't something we talk
about much in this course specifically but
you will have learned about it in the IPLT
course. Put simply implied
volatility is a forward-looking measure of
volatility using option prices in the
market which makes it
preferable really as a calculation method
over realized volatility for the most part
since
we're interested in how stocks will behave
in the future not how they have done in
the past.
Sometimes though we're forced into using
past prices to make estimates about future
volatility in
correlation because there is no better
alternative or because it's significantly
quicker and easier to
calculate. Now this summary sheet is
really just here as a guide to show you
which equities data are in the
file and therefore can be used in the
portfolio volatility calculator but I want
to quickly point out a few
things about the volatility values that we
see here. Firstly remember what I said
about volatility earlier
in that it represents both risk and
opportunity. Typically we see higher
volatility across equities than in
other asset classes and within equities
volatility and hence opportunity for
profit increases as you slide
down the market cap scale meaning lower
market cap stocks tend to be more volatile
and hence present us with
greater profit potential when we trade
them. We can see that clearly in this
table by looking at the
the volatility values for the various
equities with different market caps. The
other point I want to
make which I made earlier about volatility
was that it increases with longer time
horizons which is
quite intuitive. Trading stocks over long
time periods gives the prices longer to
move so that's why it's
intuitive that there's more volatility in
longer time horizons. So we can see here
that volatility and hence
opportunity increases increases as we go
from daily to weekly to monthly to monthly
and quarterly
frequencies of return. I'm not going to go
into any more detail on that here because
we talk a lot about
it in the IPLT course but this is why we
talk about the sweet spot for trading time
horizons being or for
retail traders being around 20 to 60
trading days. That is of course you know
dependent on market volatility as a whole.
The last thing that I want to note about
these volatility values that you see here
is that
there is sometimes quite a difference
between realised volatility and implied
volatility for a stock over
the same sort of intervals. Much of that
is to do with the fact that as I said
implied volatility is a
forward-looking measure and it takes into
account the current market environment and
the outlook that
stocks the stock's volatility has going
forward whereas realised volatility is
based on all the historical
values that have been used in the standard
deviation calculation. In this case up to
30 years of data.
These differences are particularly
apparent in this table if we look at
things like the the FAANG stocks.
If you look at stocks like Apple, Google,
Facebook you'll see that the realised
volatility calculations are
much higher than the implied volatility
calculations and that's because these
stocks have experienced massive
and rapid growth over the last 30 years
which obviously shows up in the volatility
of the stock's returns.
But now they are sort of huge maturing
businesses with diverse operations and so
realistically
their growth outlook is nothing like what
it was which is why the implied or
forward-looking
volatility values are lower. So when
you're looking at this table just be aware
of things like that.
You need to be able to understand what the
volatility values of companies are but
also why they might be different as well.
That way you can make an educated
assumption about what volatility might be
like in the future.
Okay, that was a pretty long explanation
of the summary sheet but I wanted to be
thorough.
Next up we've got the asset prices and
asset return sheets.
All of the stocks that you can see in the
summary sheet here have prices and returns
data listed in these sheets.
The price data can be easily updated using
Yahoo Finance which I'll go through a bit
later in the video
and the data in the return sheet is just
derived from the prices sheet.
I've chosen to download and generate
returns for each of these stocks on a
weekly basis simply because
that's the time frame that I like to use
to calculate covariances and correlations.
There are some of my reasons for that
which I won't go into here but if you
wanted to you could do the same
with daily or monthly prices should you
wish to do so. However, you will need to
update a couple of
calculation cells in the portfolio
volatility model as well if you do that so
I recommend just kind of
sticking to weekly data when you download
and update prices.
As I said the returns here are generated
from the prices sheet and are used for
variance and
covariance equations in our portfolio
volatility practice sheet that we're going
to be going on to
shortly. An important point here which
I'll mention again later is that all the
different price
and return data series must be the same
length as each other or the calculations
in the portfolio
volatility model won't work. So in this
case you can see that I've got prices
going back to the 16th of
July 2015 and returns to the 23rd of July
2015. Remember that whenever we calculate
returns prices over
two periods are required in the
calculation and so obviously the series
will always be one period
shorter in the return sheet than the
prices sheet. Later in the video I'm going
to go through an example
of downloading your own price data so you
can feel comfortable with modelling your
own sort of
portfolio's volatility. So all of this
leads us to the main event which is the
portfolio volatility
practice sheet. This sheet is going to
automatically calculate or model expected
portfolio volatility
on an annualised basis for any portfolio
that you build provided you've got the
correct data in the
supporting sheets I've just mentioned.
It's a great tool really for being able to
conduct scenario analysis
and to help you understand the potential
volatility that your portfolio faces
currently and under varying
circumstances when the structure of the
portfolio might change. Okay so at the top
of this sheet you'll
see a large variance covariance matrix
which can support up to 25 positions and
you can insert
any company that you have the data for
into the portfolio model just by typing
the ticker into the
orange cells running down the left hand
side in column B. On the right hand side
in column AB you can
assign the dollar net allocation to each
position in the portfolio and I'll talk
about that a bit more
as we get into our scenario examples. The
only cells that you guys should be
touching in this sheet are the
orange ones. All other cells are
calculation cells that will update
automatically based on the inputs that
you enter into those orange cells. If you
do end up editing calculation cells then
you may run into trouble
as you know there's lots of complex
formulas running behind the scenes here so
just be careful with your
inputs. Now when you download this file
the sheet will be locked so you can only
actually enter values into the orange
cells.
However, if you do want to unprotect the
sheet to play around with the formulas
then you can do so by
going to review on the ribbon followed by
unprotect sheet and then type in the
password portvol. I've
written a sort of note here quickly to
remind you of that as well inside the
sheet. As I say though you risk
it's breaking the model if you edit the
calculation calculation cells in this
sheet which is why by default
I'm locking it to kind of prevent any user
error but equally you know I don't want to
stop those of
you that are interested in doing so to
edit anything that you might wish to. So
let's continue.
variance and covariance values are
generated automatically when you have when
you enter tickers and their capital
allocations into those orange cells and
from all of those numbers a portfolio
variance figure is generated in
cell B37 in the table below. That value is
then converted to a standard deviation
figure for the frequency of data with
which you have downloaded prices.
So in this case we're using weekly prices
and returns and so this value here in cell
C40 is a
weekly standard deviation value. That
value is then converted to a more industry
standard annualized volatility number in
cell B43.
If you wanted to change the frequency of
price and returns data that you used in
the model you would need
to update the formula in this cell to
reflect that change. I advise you just
leave it as it is for simplicity and make
sure you always
use weekly price data throughout the sheet
but there is the possibility to do that if
you wanted to.
The other calculation cells that I've
included in this box here include a quick
evaluation of the
average asset standard deviation value
based on the returns data in the asset
return sheet and I've also
converted that to an annualized figure as
well. So these numbers are just kind of
useful as a reference
so that you have an idea of the average
volatility of the individual positions
that make up the portfolio.
Adjacent to this analysis box I've just
been through there's also a sort of
scenario analysis table which
we're going to get into as we go through
some scenario examples shortly.
So let's start with our first portfolio
scenario now. At the moment the portfolio
that we've got entered
here contains six stocks which are our
traditional FAANG stocks along with
Microsoft as well.
What I'm going to do in this first
scenario is build out a long only mega cap
portfolio with 10 stocks
all equally weighted. If we take a look
back to the summary page I'm just going to
pick another four mega cap stocks to add
to
this portfolio and the ones that I'm going
to choose are Disney, IBM, Caterpillar and
Striker.
So to add those to the portfolio we can
just copy and paste the tickers into the
orange cells in column B
or we can type them manually so DIS for
Disney, IBM for IBM, CAT for Caterpillar
and SYK for Striker.
Whenever you enter tickers into the
portfolio you must give them an associated
dollar net allocation.
In this portfolio we're just going to
create an equally weighted long only
portfolio of 10 mega cap stocks
with a total capital amount of capital to
allocate of $100,000 so the dollar
allocation
for each position is going to be $10,000.
Before we go any further let me quickly
talk about some mechanics of using the
sheet
specifically with reference to adding,
removing or replacing positions.
Firstly, whenever you have tickers running
down the orange cells in column B
they must always be in a continuous
unbroken list meaning there can't be a gap
between any of the
tickers that you enter. When you add an
asset to the portfolio that means you
should enter the new
ticker directly below the tickers that you
already have listed as constituents in the
portfolio.
When you remove an asset all you need to
do is delete the ticker and the associated
allocation by
clearing the contents of those cells and
then shuffle up the tickers and the
respective allocations so that
there's no gaps and it remains continuous.
If you want to replace an asset all you
have to do is type
over the ticker you wish to replace with
the new ticker and the same applies for
the new dollar allocation of course.
So essentially what we have here is a very
simple equal weighted long only mega cap
portfolio
and you can see from cell B43 that the
expected volatility for the portfolio is
calculated as 19.23%
on an annualized basis. Remember this
number is generated using the past data
that we've selected so
from mid-2015 to mid-2021 and so it's just
an estimation. It would only hold true if
the variances and
co-variances of all of the individual
assets remain constant at those same
values going forward. This
is why it's just an estimate of portfolio
volatility going forward. Before we move
on to a different
portfolio I just want you guys to take a
quick note of the average individual asset
standard deviation
level in this portfolio as well which is
around 28.28%. Okay so let's move on to a
different scenario now
where we look at another long only
portfolio but this time containing five
large and five mid cap stocks.
I've selected a sample of stocks from the
list available in this sheet to make up
the constituents
of this portfolio and those are LVS, I'm
just going to read out the tickers because
it's easier rather than
the full names, LVS, BBY, LEN, SPLK, VTRS,
XPO, MOS, FEE, TTEC and WING.
You can look up what those tickers are in
the summary sheet if you wish to or online
as you're
going through the video but like I said
it's easier just to kind of stick to the
tickers in a
example like this. So I'm going to keep
the portfolio equally weighted with ten
thousand dollars per
position and once I've entered all of
those positions we can see how the
portfolio volatility
has now changed. So with this portfolio
you can see the annualized standard
deviation is calculated as 29.36%
which is significantly more than the
previous portfolio that we looked at which
had a volatility of 19.23%.
This is largely due to the massive
increase in individual asset volatility of
the new constituents so
our average asset volatility now reads as
44.33% rather than 28.28%.
So the conclusion here is similar to that
which we've drawn previously and that is
that
there's more volatility in trading large
and mid caps compared to just mega caps.
That's good for us
because whilst it represents additional
risk it also means more opportunity for
profit. There is a bit
more to discuss about the differences in
mid and large cap portfolios compared to
mega cap ones when
it comes to portfolio volatility and
correlations but I'm going to save that
for the next video.
We're going to continue now onto our third
portfolio scenario and this one's going to
be a bit more
representative of the type of portfolio
that ITPM traders might have on because it
includes both
longs and shorts in the mid and large cap
space. So I'm going to stick with the
portfolio as it is
in terms of assets but instead of them all
being long positions I'm going to change a
few to shorts.
I think for this example what we'll do is
look at what happens when we go short four
of our large caps.
So that means we'll have a portfolio
that's long six stocks and short four and
it's predominantly
weighted to being long the smaller cap
stocks. I want to keep all the gross
weightings to each
position the same so that this portfolio
remains somewhat comparable to the
previous one but whilst
the gross allocation to each constituent
will be ten thousand dollars still the net
allocation
needs to be negative for our short
positions with the way that this model is
built. So to make that
adjustment adjustment all I'm going to do
here is make the top four positions
negative by putting a
negative sign before the allocation values
in the column AB. Now once those short
positions have been
allocated we can have a look at the
volatility analysis again. What we see
here is an absolutely
massive difference to our previous
portfolios. The annualized standard
deviation of this portfolio
is much much lower at 11.23% and that's
all the while the average asset
volatilities of the constituents
have remained the same between this one
and the last scenario because remember we
haven't actually
changed any of the stocks themselves. So
if we think back to the portfolio
volatility theory I discussed
earlier then we know that if volatility of
the portfolio has changed but the
variances or volatility of the
constituents themselves hasn't then
clearly the covariances or correlations
must have changed and
that's had a massive effect. I can tell
you now that this is because we've got a
portfolio with both
long and short positions within it rather
than just a long only portfolio. Again I'm
not going to spend too
much time discussing the correlation side
of things right now because it's something
I'm going to emphasize a
lot more in the next video instead where
I'm going to run through kind of the same
scenarios portfolio
scenarios again but from the perspective
of correlation. Okay now you might be
thinking at this stage
given what I've kind of said and taught so
far that if volatility drops that much by
having both long and
short positions aren't we forgoing
opportunity for profit. My answer to that
is no not exactly
and here's why. Firstly this is a strategy
for all markets. We're targeting absolute
returns every
year irrelevant of what happens to the
market as a whole. Of course that might
mean that occasionally you return
less than the market but you also won't
lose as much when the market goes down and
over time that means
you'll significantly outperform. Limiting
losses is essential to wealth creation and
the proof of that
is kind of the simple mathematical fact
that recovering from losses requires a
much bigger percentage gain
than the percentage loss loss suffered in
the first place. So for example if you
have a position
that loses 20 percent you need the trade
to then increase by 25 percent that's 25
percent to get back to where you started.
Secondly always consider what data your
results and analysis are based on. In
these scenarios we're working with data
over a
a roughly kind of six year historical
period. Just because the correlations
between these long and
short positions have been negative over
that period as a whole doesn't mean that
they're going to continue
to be that way when you trade your own
ideas. When you generate and time your own
trades you're
going to have positive return expectations
on both the long and short sides of your
portfolio
over the period that you're trading those
assets. If you're right obviously the
returns can be huge
and if you're wrong typically you're only
going to be wrong on one side either the
long or short side
meaning your downside is reduced. Of
course it is possible that you could be
wrong on both
the long and short sides of your portfolio
and that is going to hurt there's no doubt
about that
but if you do your homework and put into
practice the stuff that we teach in this
course
then that's going to be much much less
likely than it would have been otherwise.
Thirdly this model can only run its
calculations using returns of the stocks
themselves however many
of you will actually end up using options
to structure your trades especially if you
then move
on to do our POTM course our Professional
Options Trading Masterclass course.
Options have an implicit
leverage given that they're a fraction of
the cost for a kind of similar exposure
compared to buying or selling
the underlying stock outright and by
trading options you can control the amount
of leverage you take on
through your allocation of capital to
option premiums. So for example you might
have up to
five to ten times the volatility you would
with the underlying portfolio for the same
amount of capital
committed which obviously increases the
opportunity for profit massively. This
doesn't actually translate to a
to a directly proportionate magnified
downside either since options are
structured in such a way that downside
is limited to the premium paid and so we
can also kind of take advantage of that
and in what's called
an asymmetric risk profile. Understanding
options and you know how you can structure
ideas with them is
beyond the scope of this video and beyond
the scope of this course for the most part
but all of that
is covered in the Professional Options
Trading Masterclass video series and
that's something you can think
about doing after completing this course.
What I will talk to you briefly about
though is how options work in
terms of leverage with an example let's
consider Mosaic stock as an example. In
our portfolio above we're
assuming a long position of the value
$10,000 and Mosaic stock, so MOS is the
ticker, MOS on the 31st of August
trades at around $32 a share. So if you
bought the stock you'd get about 309
shares with your $10,000.
Let's say you have a price target of
$10,000. Let's say you have a price target
of $40 within the next
one to two months. If you're right you'd
make $8 times by 309 shares that's equal
to $2,472.
Let's compare that with buying a call
option or call options on the stock, so on
Mosaic.
This is a screenshot taken from Nasdaq.com
on the 31st of August and basically it
shows a small options
chain for Mosaic for the 15th of October
expiry. It looks like the $32 strike call
option can be bought
for around $1.83 and when you buy an
options contract for a US stock it covers
100 shares of the underlying
stock. So in this case for $10,000 you
could buy 54 of these call contracts. With
this structure
if you're right on your view that Mosaic
will reach $40 within expiry of the option
then you'd make $33,318.
The options premium for that would be
equal to $9,882 and so the profit is
worked out as $40 minus $32
times by 50 contracts, 54 contracts, sorry
times by 100 shares or options per
contract minus that options
premium of $9,882 and that's where we get
the figure $33,318. Now that's just a
really simple and crude way
of explaining the implicit leverage that
exists in options. In that example buying
the stock outright
gave you exposure to 309 shares of Moss
but by buying call options we had an
exposure to 5,400 shares
of Moss for the same cost. Granted there
are caveats such as the breakeven for
profit being $1.83 higher
and expiry on the contracts but there are
ways to mitigate or manage those risks
through things like
the idea generation process and more
sophisticated option structures that are
mentioned in our other
courses. Don't forget you can obviously
control the leverage you take as well by
reducing the premium you
spend and exposing yourself to much less
contracts if you wanted to. So it does
give you that added flexibility
and your maximum downside is limited to
the cost of the option whereas your upside
for call options is
unbounded. So you do benefit again from
that asymmetric payoff profile as well.
Typically a good trader
might get 60% of all trades might get 60%
of their trades right 40% wrong. 90 to 95%
of all their trades
over a year might sum up to a small net
profit and then there's going to be 5 to
10% of those trades
that are home runs and they're going to
generate the majority of your end of year
P&L. Now on the subject of
good traders I have another little
scenario analysis table in this sheet
which I mentioned before and that
essentially shows you what sort of return
you might expect for varying levels of
sharp ratio
given the modelled volatility in the
portfolio. The gross sharp ratio is
essentially
your annualised portfolio return divided
by annualised volatility. The higher the
number the better.
Very good retail traders should expect to
have a gross sharp ratio of around 1.5 to
2 consistently
over long periods of time. In the current
portfolio that would basically equate to a
17 to 22.5%
portfolio return per year. Remember though
that that number is likely to be magnified
if you're trading
options or using leverage in other forms.
What that means is a well traded long
short portfolio using a
structured approach with quality ideas
might make more like 75 to 100% or more in
a very good year.
Bear in mind though you know that's really
only going to be achievable with the right
education
plenty of practice with real money trading
and so on. It does take a lot of time to
trade to that kind of level.
Okay, after that brief detour into an
options example, let's return now to our
fourth and final scenario.
I want to use this example just to talk
about how you can change the weightings of
your positions and
a realistic scenario as to why you might
wish to do so. It goes without saying that
you don't have to
equally weight every position in the
portfolio as I've been doing in the
previous scenarios.
You can change the allocations in column
AB to anything you wish and the
spreadsheet model will
still work. In reality it isn't very
likely that you'll be able to have
precisely equal weightings
anyway across all your positions because
even if as in the examples we looked at
before you wanted to
allocate $10,000 to every position that
would only really be possible if the share
price of each of
those stocks was a divisor of $10,000.
Equally as the prices of these assets move
so will the inherent
weighting that you have in each position
so if you're using this sheet to gauge
your current portfolio's
expected volatility then you need to bear
that in mind as well and update it on a
regular basis.
Other factors that might affect weightings
will be your own constraints rather than
those enforced on
you by moving markets or mathematical
impossibilities. So for example in all
probability you'll want to
weight your various positions based at
least partially on your conviction of the
trades themselves.
You may also want to change allocations to
positions based on your market view i.e.
choosing
whether you're net long or short the
market as a whole in dollar terms. In the
portfolio we still have
set up from the previous scenario you can
see that at least in dollar terms we're
net long the market
since our long positions add up to $60,000
and our short positions only $40,000.
Let's say for example
that we actually want to be net neutral in
terms of market exposure in dollar terms
so we need to
redistribute our capital across our
positions to make sure our long exposure
is equal to our short exposure.
By the way this is by no means what you
should do don't take this as advice in any
way it's totally
dependent on your read of the market at
any given time and actually dollar
neutrality is just one
method to balance longs and shorts. You
could also take things a step further and
consider something
called the beta of your portfolio which
actually is something we're going to look
at in a couple of
videos time. Anyway let's assume we want
to keep the long portion of the portfolio
equally weighted and
the short portion of the portfolio equally
weighted as well. In order to create
dollar neutrality in our
longs and shorts we would need to take
$10,000 from our long positions and
reallocate that capital to
our short positions. So to do that evenly
across our longs we would take away $1,666
from each position
because we want to deduct $10,000 evenly
across six positions. That makes each
position size roughly
$8,333 afterwards. Then we would allocate
$2,500 to each of our short positions
since we only have
four of those and we need to reallocate
that $10,000 that we freed up from the
long side.
As you can see here we still basically
have the same gross exposure. We're $2 out
from where we were
just because of rounding and dividing
$10,000 by six to the nearest dollar on
the long side
but for the purposes of what we're doing
here that $2 is pretty irrelevant so don't
get caught up on it.
If we take a look at the analysis portion
of the sheet again now you can see that by
keeping
exactly the same positions and just
altering the weightings the expected
portfolio volatility has
changed. It's actually decreased by about
1.5% from 11.23% to 9.66% now. If you
think about it
that makes some sense because we've now
redistributed capital more evenly across
our longs and shorts
which have negative correlations and thus
reduce the overall volatility. Again we'll
talk about that
more in the next video. So there's some
examples of why you might want to change
weightings in each
asset and how you can actually do that in
this model. It's all simple stuff really
and that's
that's kind of all I wanted to cover in
this scenario analysis section. I think
you guys probably
have a good understanding now of how you
can use the model by running through those
situations I
just been through and so all that's left
in this video now is for me to show you
some of the
practicalities involved in using this
spreadsheet yourselves for your own
portfolios. Okay so when
it comes to you guys using this
spreadsheet my suggestion to you is to
first use it as it stands to get
used to the mechanics of sort of how it
works and what you can do with it. Then
once you've sort of built
some understanding and you think you're
ready you can start making changes to the
underlying data to
reflect your own watch lists and
portfolios. So with that being said let me
talk about how you would do
that. Firstly you'll want to delete all of
the tickers and data that you see in the
prices sheet that you
don't want or need to update which will
likely be all of it. Second you'll need to
download new weekly price
data from Yahoo Finance for the stocks
that you want to be able to model
portfolio for
and finally that data will need to be
cleaned and manipulated to make sure that
the time series of
prices and returns are equal and over the
exact same intervals for all assets and
then it's going to be
ready for analysis in the rest of the
sheet and you can sort of do some modeling
in this portfolio
volatility practice sheet. So let me run
through these steps now as I said we start
with deleting
the underlying data currently in the
spreadsheet in the asset prices sheet. So
to do that I'm just going
to go to the asset prices sheet left click
on column c and then press ctrl shift and
right on the keyboard twice
to select all of the columns of data that
we have here in this sheet and then press
delete on the keyboard
to clear the contents of all of those
cells. The next step is to download the
price data that you want
for the assets that you want to be able to
include in your portfolio volatility
model. Now in this example
what I'm going to do is grab some data for
three new stocks they are Thor Industries
ticker THO,
Papa John's ticker PZZA and Herman Miller
ticker MLHR. So let's start by downloading
weekly price data
for Thor Industries. So to do that I'm
going to navigate to Yahoo Finance so
finance.yahoo.com
and then I'm going to put in the ticker
for Thor Industries in the top search bar
THO and then select
the correct drop down menu option for Thor
Industries. And then we're going to go to
the historical data tab
here on the next page and what I'm going
to do is basically download all of the
historical data available.
So in this time period parameter I'm going
to select the drop down and click max and
show historical prices
frequency we're going to set to weekly so
I'm getting weekly data weekly prices for
this asset over its
entire historical data set so I'm going to
click apply and then download. As you've
seen in previous videos
when you kind of download data from Yahoo
Finance and other places when I'm doing it
I'm using Google
Chrome so I get a little shortcut to open
the file that I've just downloaded here so
I'm just going
to click that that's going to open the
file in Excel so we can view it.
And then with that data downloaded I'm
just going to expand the date column
quickly so we can see all of
those dates with that data downloaded we
need to arrange the dates in a descending
order which leaves us
with the most recent price data at the top
of the sheet and makes the data cleaning
process just a
little bit easier going forward. So to do
that I'm going to select cell A1 and go to
data on the ribbon
followed by filter that adds filters to
all of those columns of data and then I'm
going to select the
drop down filter in the date column and
then sort from newest to oldest. Okay so
the next thing to
kind of note here or look for is just
check the most recent row of data and see
whether that actually
represents a complete week of data because
depending on the day you download it from
Yahoo Finance it might
not represent a complete week. In this
case I think it does it looks like it does
so we don't need to
worry about doing anything here but if it
didn't you just delete that row so I just
delete row two here
by right clicking on that row and going to
delete in the selection. As I said in this
case we don't need
to worry about doing that here so what I'm
going to do is instead just copy the date
column and adjusted
close column prices straight into our
portfolio volatility spreadsheet so I'm
going to left click
column A hold control and left click
column F as well press ctrl c on the
keyboard so that's going to
select both those columns and copy them
then I'm going to go back to the portfolio
volatility spreadsheet
into the asset prices sheet and I'm just
going to paste those into columns C and D
as values and I'm going to do that by
right clicking column C and then selecting
the paste as values option which is the
clipboard with the one
two three on it and that's going to paste
those two columns into column C and D as
values. The reason why
I'm doing it as values is just because
previously I had this sheet set up to show
dates in in that format
so that just saves me a job from importing
or copying in all that data into columns C
and D
exactly in the same format as it was when
we downloaded it and then we're going
through the
process of changing how we see those dates
to make it look like this format. So
anyway from there we can
just rename the column title for column D
okay so this is weekly prices for THO Thor
industry so I'm going to
rename cell D1 as the ticker for that
company THO. Now what I want to do is sort
of turn my attention to
the asset return sheet currently we still
got all of our old data in here except you
know for most of it
well for all of it it's incorrect actually
because our tickers are named incorrectly
but we're getting
some returns pulled through into column D
here and some dates in column C that's
because it is referencing
those two columns that we've just pulled
through in the prices sheet we just need
to kind of rename D1
cell D1 here from the visa ticker to the
Thor industries ticker so I can just write
that in there
for the other cells that's all incorrect
obviously it's trying to pull through data
in cells that don't
have any prices returns it's trying to
sort of calculate returns from cells that
don't have prices so
what I'm going to do is just select all of
the columns from E onwards with control
shift and
write on the keyboard and then press
delete on the keyboard to clear the
contents of those cells
now what we want to do is just check that
all the returns in this column column D
are actually
pulling through correctly or calculating
correctly using prices from the other
sheet
if we double click into cell D2 you'll see
that that formula is calculated from the
price in D2 divided by
the price in D3 in the prices sheet minus
one okay so we know that that's going to
be correct for those
returns the formulas are correct and all
we need to do then is basically check the
length of the series
and see you know what that is compared to
our price series so our price series goes
down it goes back to
1984 okay row 1967 so that means we can
actually copy these formulas down all the
way down to
one nine six six okay so let's do that now
okay so we've got returns going all the
way back if we did copy it down to row one
nine six seven we'd get
an error because we don't have prices you
know from the row one nine six eight which
is required for
that returns formula so I've explained
that before so we just delete the contents
for that row back to row
one nine six six so let me just explain
you know what I just went through in case
that wasn't clear
basically we're downloading prices from
yahoo finance for three new stocks okay
because those are stocks
we're saying in this example we're
interested in for our own portfolio to so
to start with I cleared
all the prices in the prices sheet for all
the stocks that we had before and then I
downloaded new
prices for one of our tickers one of our
stocks that were interested in Thor
Industries imported or copied
those prices into this sheet in columns c
and d or the dates in column c and the
prices in column d
when I copied those in I copied them and
pasted them as values the reason why I
pasted them as values
is so that we kept whatever formatting we
had already in this sheet and that was
useful to us basically
so I didn't have to reformat the dates
column to make it look like this okay and
then what we wanted to do
or what we did was check the return sheet
okay and we saw that obviously it still
had all the previous
tickers that we were looking at in this
spreadsheet so we needed to delete all of
those and make sure
that the column d was still calculating
returns correctly from the prices that it
sees in the in
column d from the prices sheet which it
did but the length of the prices column
that we had for
Thor Industries compared to all the data
we had in the spreadsheet previously was
quite different it was
a lot longer okay so that means that we
could copy the returns formula down for
Thor Industries
all the way down to row 1966 okay so just
remember that when you're doing this
process when you're going
through this process and putting in new
prices and new returns you need to make
sure that the tickers always match up in
the
right columns okay and then you're not
going to have any issues you know you're
not going to misunderstand
which returns match to which prices so
long as they're always in the same columns
and the tickers
are named the same and also when it comes
to putting those tickers into your
portfolio model in the
portfolio volatility practice sheet it
will actually pull through correctly
because that requires that you
enter whatever is in the column title
cells in order to pull through that data
so it's easier just to keep it
all as the tickers for the stocks so now
what we want to do is just repeat that
process for the other
companies that we're interested in so
let's do that now starting with Papa
John's so I'm just going
to go back to the Yahoo Finance website
and in the top search bar this time put in
PZZA which is the ticker
for Papa John's then I'm going to select
that drop down and go to the historical
data tab again
again select the time period as max choose
a weekly frequency click apply and
download
that's going to download our weekly prices
for Papa John's okay I'm going to open
that spreadsheet now
make the date column a little bit wider so
we can see that I need to go through the
same process again
for arranging our dates in a descending
order so to do that I'm selecting cell A1
I'm going to go to data
on the ribbon and then filter that's going
to add filters to all of the columns in
this data set I'm
then going to click on the filter for the
date column and sort by newest to oldest
so that's going to sort
all of our prices by the newest date to
the oldest date what I'm then going to do
is seeing that all the
dates match the prior dates that we
downloaded for Thor Industries I'm going
to just copy column F
by selecting it and pressing ctrl C on the
keyboard and then I'm going to copy that
into
our portfolio volatility asset prices
sheet so I'm going to select column E here
and then right click
in that selection and just paste as values
again that's going to paste all of that
data into that column
for those relevant weekly dates of course
then I need to change the column title so
that we know you know
what company these prices are for so the
company is PZZA Papa John's and then I'm
going to check
before we move any further the length of
this data set compared to the length of
Thor Industries
price data so I'm pressing ctrl and down
on the keyboard and that's taking me down
to row 1476 in
column E and we can see that the price
data set for Papa John's is a lot shorter
than for Thor Industries
now remember what I said earlier for this
portfolio model to work portfolio
volatility model to work
in order to calculate the underlying
covariances and variances the length of
each data series needs to
be exactly the same so that basically
means we need to delete all of the data
that isn't common to all
of the stocks that we have in this sheet
so every time you add new stocks this is
probably going to
change you're going to have to go through
a process of deleting data potentially
perhaps not every time
obviously it depends on the length of the
data series but in this example we need to
do that so what I'm
going to do is delete all of the dates and
prices for Thor Industries from row 1477
down because that
is not common to the new data that we have
for Papa John's so I'm just selecting
those two cells C and D
1477 pressing ctrl shift down on the
keyboard and delete on the keyboard to
clear the contents for all of
those and that means we've got an even
price series for those two assets let's go
over to the return
sheet now and basically update this so
that it includes returns for Papa John's
in cell E1 I'm going
to head the column with pzza making sure
that is the same ticker that we're using
in both the prices and
the return sheets and the return sheets
and obviously the one that we'll end up
using in the model as well
from there I'm going to copy across
the returns formula that we have in cell
D2 for Thor Industries across one column
to cell E2
then we can just check this formula it's
calculating returns based on the prices
sheet whatever's in cell E2 divided by
E3-1
we know that's going to be correct because
we've imported prices into column E so
that's fine
and we can just copy that formula down all
the way to the bottom of that data set
now what do we have here currently we've
got a load of errors and what looks like
dates
that are kind of non-existent okay so
what's happened here basically we've
deleted a load of data in the
prices sheet for Thor Industries okay so
that our price columns match in their
length for Thor Industries
and Papa John's that's meant that this
return sheet is no longer referencing or
it's referencing blank cells
and so that's created a load of errors in
our returns for Thor Industries and also
the dates are now incorrect in their
reference as well so we just need to make
sure
that whenever we download new prices and
then change the length of the price series
we need to do the same for the returns and
remember the returns is always going to be
one row less in length than prices okay so
I'm deleting from row 1476 and down this
time
so selecting all of those cells C to E
1476 pressing ctrl shift and down on the
keyboard
delete on the keyboard to clear all of
that contents and then going back to the
top of the sheet
okay so we've done two out of three of the
stocks that we're going to look at
let's continue on to the third one now
which is Herman Miller so if we go back to
Yahoo Finance type in the
ticker for Herman Miller which is MLHR and
then select that stock from the drop down
menu
and then go to historical data choose max
again as our time period and the frequency
as weekly prices
and then click apply and download that's
going to download all the prices for
Herman Miller we can open
that sheet and we're just going to go
through exactly the same process as we did
before going to increase
the width of the date column I'm going to
add filters okay so that we can sort the
date column now from
newest to oldest and then I'm just going
to make sure the dates look like they
match exactly the same dates
as we had for the other two stocks and
then I'm just going to copy column F the
adjusted close prices
into our portfolio volatility sheet in the
asset prices sheet and paste them into
column F here
as values remembering always to rename the
column heading cell so cell F1 in this
case to
whatever the relevant ticker is so MLHR in
this case and then checking the length of
the price series
okay so in this case we've got a price
series that is way longer than what we've
kind of shortened
our previous two price series down to so
basically we've got prices that go back
further than the
7th of June 1993 the simple thing that we
need to do here is basically just delete
all of the data
from those cells beyond or before rather
the 7th of June 1993 for Herman Miller so
I'm just selecting cell
F1477 in this case control shift and down
to select all of the data below it delete
on the keyboard to
clear the contents and back up to the top
and that's all we need to do to even out
our price series
finally we just want to do the same thing
in our asset return sheet as we've done
before
so I'm putting in the ticker for the new
stock which is MLHR into cell F1 and then
I'm going to copy across
the returns formula from cell E1 to F1 and
then copy it down as well quickly scroll
down to the bottom
of the data series and check that that's
all okay at which it is so now we've got
an even price series
and an even return series as well and with
all of our price data and returns data
sort of inputted and
cleaned for the three stocks we can now
add them into the portfolio practice sheet
and start modeling
volatility and correlation so for example
let's just do that very quickly now I'm
just going to
delete all of the tickers that we can see
in the orange cells now currently in the
portfolio volatility
model and delete all of the dollar
allocations as well then just put in our
three stocks our three
stocks being THO PZZA and MLHR you can see
all the data starting to pull through
already let's just
give each of those an allocation of ten
thousand dollars we're just basically
checking this is where
this works I just want to show you how
simple this all is and that's it we've got
a three stock portfolio
and we've got a portfolio standard
deviation calculated based on all of that
data and that's
all there is to it now obviously with this
portfolio the difference between kind of
this one and the
last one obviously the companies involved
and the number of companies and so on but
also the fact that
all of these covariances and variances are
being calculated based on a much longer
series of data okay
so going from September 2021 back to June
1993 you can of course use any sort of
time period time window
you want so just because you can get all
the data for these three stocks going back
that far doesn't
mean you need to model your volatility
based on price data and returns data from
that entire period
if you wanted you could just model it on
you know the last well let's say from 2010
onwards okay
so you could just delete everything from
2009 and before for both prices and
returns remember
and the portfolio model would still work
it would be slightly different we get a
slightly different
portfolio volatility number but it would
it would still work and that's really down
to your preference
how you want to kind of choose the time
window that you want to work with I am
going to mention
something about that in the next video as
well when we kind of consider correlations
in more detail
okay great that's all I really wanted to
cover in this video let me just finish up
with some concluding
remarks about what we've covered and also
you know what you need to take away from
this video
to begin I introduced the concept of
volatility and explained how volatility
needs to be reframed in
your mind as both risk and opportunity
since if there's no volatility in prices
then there's no
chance for capital gains in the assets you
trade we didn't spend too long on all of
that because
it's covered pretty extensively in the
IPLT course and again for those of you
that haven't done it
already I do strongly encourage you guys
to do so we then moved on to how
volatility is typically measured
with a statistic called standard deviation
I showed that although statistics like
that might sometimes feel
a bit sort of opaque and hard to
understand if you break down the
principles it's usually quite simple
in the case of a standard deviation it's
basically just calculating some kind of
average variation of a data
series from a reference point and for a
standard deviation the reference point is
the average of the entire series itself
with that background covered it allowed me
to move on and talk through calculating
portfolio volatility
one way to do that is using realized
portfolio returns and going through
something called a distribution
of returns in which standard deviation
calculations just represent one way of
gauging historical volatility of
an asset or in this case a portfolio that
you're looking at I use the portfolios
that we covered in the
previous video in the examples for
continuity and also to kind of reinforce
the idea of smaller cap
stocks having more volatility and hence
opportunity for profit than larger cap
stocks the other way to
calculate portfolio volatility is with a
modeling equation and what that allows us
to do is use assumptions for
inputs of variance covariance and
weightings for all of the portfolio
constituents and compute an output
of estimated volatility in this
spreadsheet we're calculating variance and
covariances of assets using historical
data
specifically the assets weekly returns all
of that is basically done under the hood
of the spreadsheet model
so all that's required for us to retrieve
is for us to do is retrieve historical
prices and returns for
the portfolio constituents we want and
then enter those tickers into the
portfolio model and analyze the output
anyway before we went into all of the
scenario analysis and practicalities of
using the spreadsheet I talked
you through some important portfolio
theory or portfolio volatility theory we
learned that the volatility of
a portfolio is a function of both the
individual constituents variances and
their covariances and that
actually as assets are added to the
portfolio it's the relationships between
assets that are much more
important to the overall volatility of the
portfolio than the individual positions
volatilities themselves
and this is an important distinction in
understanding the volatility of individual
assets and the
volatility of portfolios whilst we
appreciate that volatility always
represents opportunity as well as risk
when it comes to portfolios it's possible
to take advantage of positions with decent
volatility
decent volatility outlooks and hence good
profit potential whilst also combining
them in such a way
That risk is that risk is controlled at
the portfolio level in our profit and loss
an efficiently diversified
portfolio is one that takes advantage of
low correlations between constituents to
reduce risk while maintaining
strong expected returns across every
position and hence the portfolio as a
whole as i've said a few times
already in this video i'm going to talk a
little bit more about portfolio
correlation in the next video and these
ideas are going to be
reiterated there again now despite
mentioning the advantages of adding low
correlation positions to the portfolio we
need to remember not to fall into traps
such as over diversification
which is where you start adding positions
to the portfolio in the pursuit of
lowering risk for the sake of it and by
doing so actually ruining the return side
of the equation
and this tends to happen when people
ignore the importance of going through all
of their fundamental analysis and timing
protocols for each position
and basically diversify without conviction
about the underlying trade themselves
that's a huge mistake we're aiming for
portfolios and watch lists full of really
really strong ideas and the
consideration of how those ideas fit
together in a portfolio only comes
afterwards so the consideration of
correlations or anything like that how it
fits together is all secondary to
the concept of idea generation generating
really strong fundamental fundamentally
driven ideas
in the next part of the video we went on
to looking at using the portfolio
volatility model under various scenarios
i went through um the examples for two
core reasons really firstly to illustrate
how the models actually use how you add
subtract and substitute positions in the
portfolio
as well as how you can change their
weightings and whether the positions are
long or short
secondly if you think back to those first
two scenarios the core takeaway was that
mega cap and large cap portfolios tend to
be less volatile than portfolios that
incorporate mid caps
that reinforces our knowledge that mid cap
positions yield us greater opportunity for
profit than larger caps because of their
increased volatility
however despite that there is also greater
scope for building lower correlation
portfolio structures when
involving mid caps as well so there is the
potential to take advantage of their
higher expected returns
whilst also managing the risk at the
portfolio level so that it doesn't
increase proportionately
essentially what i'm saying here is is
that incorporating mid cap stocks into a
portfolio
gives us the possibility to improve our
risk adjusted returns which is one of the
things that we're aiming for
as traders and portfolio managers as
you'll see later in the video series
the third scenario we went through
represented the typical type of portfolio
an itpm trader might hold
which was one that was both long and short
mid and large cap stocks
and by being both long and short various
assets the portfolio volatility was
reduced massively largely due to
the much lower correlations between
positions again this is yet another way
that risk adjusted returns can be
increased further
despite the reduction in volatility it's
important to remember that that doesn't
necessarily
mean less opportunity for profit for a
number of reasons the key ones being that
having a long
short portfolio is a strategy that can
work in all markets and also that you can
increase upside
significantly by structuring trades with
leveraged products such as options now
structuring portfolios with
options to obtain better risk reward
dynamics is something we cover more in our
professional options trading course
but what it means is that whilst you might
model a small and large cap long short
portfolio having say
10 to 15 percent annualized volatility
once you account for the implicit leverage
in trading those positions
through options the actual volatility
could be substantially higher if so
desired and with these structures
the downside risk doesn't have to be or
doesn't need to increase proportionally to
the upside opportunity either
given the asymmetric profile of options
and when you sort of couple that with a
high trading performance
as measured by the Sharpe ratio
prospective profits can become very very
attractive
in the final section of the video we went
through some practical aspects of using
this spreadsheet
model ourselves with your own portfolio of
assets so that you can make more informed
decisions and
come to a greater understanding of your
own portfolios and what to expect from
them
we're going to build on this in the next
video where we discuss correlation in more
detail and i'll be adding
a bit of analysis to this spreadsheet
model so that you can monitor correlations
throughout your portfolios in more detail
okay guys well done in this one that's
that's not an easy video and obviously
there's a lot to take in
don't get too bogged down with it all just
yet like i said in the introduction make
sure you watch the next video
before worrying too much about this one
and kind of take them as a pair because
that will really help your understanding
also for those of you that have access go
back to the IPLT course if you need to
understand a bit more about volatility in
general
that's it for this one though and i'll see
you in the next video